spring in John Barry a veteran NBA
player and now works for ESPN radio on
the mothership John good morning how are
you hello how's your load management
today I'm gonna golf today I'm not gonna
take the day off
I like that you're a true warrior give
it a go yeah I mentioned that this
became a big deal because ESPN was
carrying the game last night
and then Kauai doesn't play now you have
all the ESPN entities talking about load
management therefore it becomes a big
big story today load management's been
around here but the fact that he missed
a nationally televised game last night
where do you stand on load management if
you were a plane and you were on the
Clippers and Kauai and or Paul George or
sitting out 12 games 15 games this year
with load management how would you feel
well first of all my first six years in
the league doctors never told me not to
play with the coaches look now I I see
every different side and it's very
difficult it's it's a problem I see the
franchise side I see the coach decide I
see the players side I see the fans side
each one maybe being different players
collide missed what 22 games last year
something like yeah so he's playing a 60
game season if he does that for four
straight years he's saving another year
of earning power that he can play
another year in the league and make 35
40 million dollars so I understand you
know when you get suspended you lose a
game check so why should you get a game
check if you're sitting on the sidelines
when you could probably play
that's another angle coaches the
ultimate goal is to win an NBA
championship
Gregg Popovich started this many many
years ago and if that's what they deemed
to be the best way to go about winning a
championship by resting their players
during the year then you do it it worked
for Gregg Popovich five times
but you also look and you say Michael
Jordan won six titles in those eight
years with the two years off in between
he missed six games in those six years I
read something Wilt Chamberlain averaged
forty eight and a half minutes a game
one season did you see this yeah he
averaged over what a regular season mini
game is he missed seven minutes in an 80
game season but-but-but Jon would would
Michael Jordan take part in load
management would Larry Bird like Larry
Bird could have extended his career
maybe with load management a Steve Nash
with load management maybe it could have
extended his career so to be fair to
today's athlete would have yesterday's
athlete given today's circumstances in
salaries you know taking part in load
management I I don't I don't think so
you know I can't speak for you know the
greatest players in the world but I
don't think Michael Jordan would waste a
minute of his time when he's as good as
he's the best in the game why not play
you know it's just like you know the
move LeBron made to LA last year
there's no way Michael Jordan would have
done that he's in his prime and to have
an opportunity to go to the finals and
win another championship he's not taking
a year off Larry Bird I don't believe is
taking a year off I think these guys
would play and you would think with all
the things that we have going on for
these players how much easier it is to
play how much better athletes they are
how much better taken care of they are
that you don't need to be resting these
guys back in the day we're flying
commercial four games in five nights
they didn't have masseuses they didn't
have buffets at every you know when they
pulled up at the locker room every night
they you know ice bags were make your
own do your own laundry like it's it's
so much easier now you would think that
these guys would be playing more and
having more of a love to play what is
the solution I don't know because you
can't just have some arbitrary NBA
person say come look at you and say you
you were capable of playing because you
say look my hamstrings a little tweaked
you can't you can't it can't happen
it just can't I'm waiting for the day
where we get coach's management load
management once a coach gonna take a
night off
well member with Phil Jackson if Phil
Jackson came back he was gonna the rumor
was that he was going to do just home
games yeah yeah I mean I was physically
he was very yeah for him to fly and sit
and do all that yeah yeah so hey Doc
Rivers has got 14 assistants over there
he can take a night off I got into this
discussion with Reggie Miller a couple
of days ago that you know I LeBron is if
he's not the underdog but he's playing
up this underdog role and he's playing
it really well right now I get into this
discussion with Reggie I said LeBron to
me is still the best player in the NBA
and he of course says I'm crazy that
it's Kawhi how do you think is the best
player in the NBA
yeah I think Hawaii certainly inching
their but as an ultimate teammate I just
think LeBrons that guy
I know call him call Matt Dellavedova
and have on your show he's making nine
and a half million now the hell is
Dellavedova still in the NBA John well
well look LeBron James I mean the guy
was he was factor for the Cleveland
Cavaliers you know in the finals because
he played with LeBron James now I don't
know that it's Matt dellavedova's
alongside Kawhi Leonard that he gets a
40 million dollar contract I don't think
I think LeBron James makes people better
more as good as anybody in the league
has ever seen and they have to be a
certain type of player now you know you
know you got to be a Kyle Korver you got
to be a stanch ars stand still shooters
you know they benefit the most from
LeBron James what do you think of the
Lakers you know that product they put on
the floor are they like is that
sustainable is that going to be are they
going to be the team to beat or one of
the two best teams in the league I think
they can be up there yeah I do like the
Clippers
when Paul George's back I think that's
the best team in the league primarily
because the defense they can play but
yeah I do think LA I'm they've come
together a lot quicker than I thought I
thought there was going to be a bigger
learning curve here but they have an
opportunity
yeah I mean I think those are the best
two teams in basketball with you know
Milwaukee Philly Boston behind that but
you also have LeBron we're talking to
John Berry of ESPN you know you have
LeBron sort of featuring Anthony Davis
is this the way it's going to be the
entire season I think that's what LeBron
is always asked for and never played
that way yeah I mean remember he just
said yeah I need some help I want all
the pressure off me but at the end of
the day he's a guy that's going to
handle the ball an awful lot but Anthony
Davis is a different dynamic that he's
had in both Miami and Cleveland
obviously had great players in Dwyane
Wade Chris Bosh Kevin Love but this is a
guy that can single-handedly take over
games I don't know that those other guys
at there that stage in their careers
were able to do that but ad can do this
and yeah I you know I think LeBron will
pick his spots he's the smartest player
as we have in the game and they'll be
nice we don't have to go for 38 and
they'll be nice when he does he can go
for 15 I'm watching James Harden last
night he still hasn't gotten his shot
this year but I when did he become
unstoppable
was he and unstoppable in college we
just didn't see it or when he was coming
off the bench at Oklahoma City and we
just didn't see it yeah I think it was
when he got to the Houston and just knew
that it was his team he was the man but
I'll tell you people don't understand
how hard that step-back is he's doing I
mean he's shooting a ball from you know
sometimes 24 26 feet stepping back I
mean the strength you have to have guys
were right in his face it doesn't matter
he gets fouled and makes those shots I
mean he's as good a one-on-one player as
this league seen in a long long time is
he as good as Jordan one-on-one of
course not yes he is I you know I'm 50
now so I guess I'm just going with the
old guard but man I wish people would
watch a little more Michael well I
wouldn't know I wouldn't bet against
Jordan if there was a game if it was
one-on-one of really anything with
Jordan but I do think that hard
is a moral you can play him and go yeah
because he he lies about his handicap he
makes himself better it with his handy
most people lie about their handicap to
make themselves worse but true
Jordan lies about being a better golfer
than he actually is
there's nothing better than an ego
handicap you could take Jordan in golf
right yeah well yes yeah yeah all right
I have I'm trying to get down to this
new place so with these listening call
now when you play how much do you play
for with Jordan it's usually just a $500
five 1s all meaning meaning so you can
play maximum of a thousand on each nine
holes and then 500 for the victory some
of us a max of 2,500
how much joint is he tone well look I
haven't played in the same group he he
met in Vegas during the during the NBA
all-star game years ago and he basically
said ten o'clock meet on the first tee
at shadow Creek and there'd be 28 guys
there and he would grab he would grab
his group and he'd look back and say I
got this with you this with you this
with you this he'd finished the round
first about an hour and a half before
anybody else and then his caddie would
sit on the 18th green and you'd come by
and everybody would hand the card to the
caddie and he trying to have a lot of
money and find out if you won or lost he
walk into the locker room Michael says
how do i do again suggested well I got
you all five ways damn I'll get you next
time because he's so competitive I would
think you'd go come on let's go back out
well yeah I'm always up for an e 9
particularly after I won 5 do what he
bets the race is what's your next game
what do you got going on Oh that'd be
Christmas oh wow that's load management
here John man oh you know it's a tough
gig Thanksgiving it you know a lot of
things going on yeah Paige
yourself good god John pace yourself for
you thanks good maybe I'll come visit
you oh yeah come on into the man cave
here you can uh you can show us how to
shoot I'm on that floor on those breaks
is just incredible do you see any hope
here like anybody decent when you look
at the den it's out there shooting hoops
Satan seems pretty good yeah buddy
what about McLovin not the best stroke
that I saw okay
McLovin didn't have the best room a
Clemens pretty good it's a little too
Hana dish which is kind of weird wait
what is it too much hands we handed to
hands left hand oh yeah yummy look like
a kind of a double double I don't know I
just look it was rocky and critique oh
look I have to be there man okay yeah my
club de Peter I was liking some YouTube
videos I definitely Brent has the better
shot than John no that's not true oh no
no I'll give Brent a lot of love but
when it comes to shooting John Barry's
got great form John can shoot he's just
a far better athlete that's all yes he
was a better player but not a better
shooter than you no I'm not going I said
athlete you know Jeff Van Gundy and he
yeah and no he'll give you the critique
so you're a better player your brother
was more athletic well I mean not to
each his own I you know I gonna enjoyed
my competitiveness I think my shooting
he was a great player don't get me wrong
I'm not disregarding him but I'm um I'll
take myself and if I have to you know
get after it
thank you John
you know it's sorry to interrupt your
rest for that Christmas Day tilt that
you're going to Thanks I'm doing some
reading I'll be alright thank you John
that's a John Barry no age it's just Jo
in for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]